payet 3.3 millions de personnes et vous
dire du sénat je pense que c'est des
montants 1 qui vont aider
c'est sûr le but le gouvernement est là
pour aider des citoyens le ministre des
finances eric girard qui présentait sa
mise à jour économique hier et ce soir
on se demande quel sera l'impact réel
pour les contribuables pour les ménages
des mesures dette dont il parlait la
face à la hausse du coût de la vie on va
faire une analyse avec le goût titulaire
de la chaire de recherche en fiscalité
et en finances publiques à l'université
de sherbrooke bonsoir monsieur godbout
bonsoir alors d'abord là j'aimerais
qu'on se concentre un petit mot d'abord
sur les finances publiques on se permet
des dépenses clairement le déficit est
en recul quelle est votre lecture face à
ça mais la lecture c'est que l'économie
est plus forte que prévu donc elles
résistent mieux à la
pandémie si bien que les déficits sont
plus modestes
le niveau d'endettement est plus modeste
et ça laisse de la marge de manoeuvre au
gouvernement pour entreprendre de
nouvelles initiatives
les mesures qu'on va analyser à
l'instant en font partie ouais d'abord
donc cette nouvelle prestation unique
pour personnes à faible revenu pour
faire face à la hausse du coût de la vie
est une mesure exceptionnelle ça
évidemment qui coûte somme toute assez
cher expliqué nous oui c'est la preuve
que ça va vite lorsqu'on veut aider les
gens donc la prestation est exceptionnel
c'est 200 $ par adulte donc incorporer 4
400 dollars une personne seule aurait
droit 275 $ et le critère
d'admissibilité le pool pour les gens
pour savoir si les hongrois c est ce
qu'ils ont droit au crédit d'impôt pour
la solidarité si oui automatiquement il
va avoir droit à la prestation
exceptionnelle du coût de la vie elle
leur sera versée à la fin du mois de
janvier en même temps que le crédit pour
s'adapter et vous avez raison de
souligner ces trois quart de milliard
ses 740 millions pour ce versement
unique way qui touche quand même
monsieur gérard le mentionnait la plus
de 3 millions de québécois alors ça
c'est comme un premier volet si on veut
il ya aussi une bonification du montant
pour les aînés de 70 ans et plus comment
ça fonctionne cette bonification alors
tout d'abord c'est une mesure que le
gouvernement de la caq a aimé ou pouvoir
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés au pouvoir en
2019 2018 2019 est un des premiers
gestes qui l'ont fait alors cette mesure
là elle fonctionne elle est actuellement
de 209 $ par citoyen est passé un
certain seuil de revenu qui est assez
modeste on voit qu'elle réduise est
quand même assez rapidement et on l'a
perdu par la suite ils viennent les
doubler elle passe de 209 $ à 409
dollars ça c'est par personne et on par
la prestation progressivement dans le
cas d'une personne seule comme on peut
le voir on voit qu'il ya plus de gens
qui vont en bénéficier
parce que le niveau de revenus est plus
élevée avant qu'on ait perdu
complètement la prestation qui on voit
que donc convié de bonifier un couple
aurait droit à huit cents à 800 dollars
cependant le plus du double donc le
total des deux prestations là pour les
années ça pourrait donner combien alors
pour un et un ennemi personnes seules de
70 ans et plus il pourrait cumuler les
deux ensemble ça 13 675 $ puis pour un
couple de rennais de 70 ans et plus qui
sont admissibles au montant de soutien
pour aînés ils pourraient avoir droit
jusqu'à 800 dollars est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure saligue debout mais si on
prend les mesures ponctuelles pour le
coût de la vie c'est une bonne mesure
dans la mesure où on estime que beaucoup
d'inflation dans l'année 2021 et que
l'indexation du régime d'imposition pour
2022 s'arrête pour le mot pour les 12
derniers mois s'arrête au 30 septembre
donc on intègre une inflation qui va
avoir lieu cet automne c'est pour ça
qu'on met cette mesure transitoire là et
en 2023 lorsqu'on est d'extraire la
prochaine fois des régimes l'inflation
va avoir été correctement intégrées au
régime d'imposition ouais bon cela dit
d'autres mesures qui ont été présentés
dans cette mise à jour bonification du
taux de crédit d'impôt remboursable pour
les frais de garde d'ailleurs vous le
savez a préparé un graphique qui montre
le comparatif entre la nouvelle mesure
est ce qui existait déjà expliqué nous
mais d'abord c'est une mesure qui est
qui et significatives c'est une besoin
pour les ménages qui ont qui ont des
enfants mais qui n'ont pas accès légal
aux garderies
la contribution réduite donc c'est pour
les ménages qui envoie les enfants en
garderie privée ce qu'on voit dans le
tableau c'est que l'ancien anciennement
le crédit était d'un maximum de 75% et
qu'il réduisait plus au fur et à mesure
que le revenu familial augmenter jusqu'à
26% pour les familles avec le revenu le
plus élevé le changement est quand même
assez significatif le taux maximum du
crédit va passer de 75 à 78 une
augmentation qui est quand même modèle
mais la réduction du crédit au fur et à
mesure que le revenu des ménages
augmente vos diminuer beaucoup moins
pour des ménages qui ont entre 60 et 100
mille dollars il y aurait eu 60% crédit
remboursable du québec d'un pour leurs
frais de garde admissibles on va
maintenant avoir soixante dix pour ça
puis pour des ménages plus riches qui
ont plus de 65 mille dollars de revenus
il aurait eu le minimum de 26 %
maintenant le minimum il va être à 67%
donc ça vient vraiment réduire le coût
net de garde pour les familles qui
envoient leurs enfants garderies privées
et les coulées les frais de garde qui
sont payés sont tous admissibles à la
déduction du côté d'ottawa donc on vient
réduire le coût net de garde de manière
sensible est ce que ce sont des dépenses
qui étaient nécessaires ou est-ce que
c'est électorale monsieur joe girardi
qui ai pas pensé aux élections depuis un
an l'homme et vous en pensez quoi il
n'ya pas passer aux élections mais si
les finances publiques étaient en moins
bon état si le déficit cette année
s'annonçait pour être plus grand que
prévu les trois gestes qu'on a parlé ce
fonds pour l'année 2000 21 dont qui ont
des conséquences dans l'immédiate c'est
parce qu'on est con on a dégagé une
marge de manoeuvre cette année qu'on
peut se permettre de faire ça aussi
rapidement le godbout merci beaucoup
pour votre analyse au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh